so you guys are gonna have to bear with
me because I'm a little bit emotional
today the first reason is that as I was
rounding the corner on via Ortega I
rented the corner on you know where
Panama and via Ortega or Panama Campus
Drive connect and that's actually the
building where I saw my Soros ten years
ago this is our tenth anniversary year
so it's really exciting to be back here
and sadly my car hasn't been upgraded
much in the last ten years which you'll
learn as a social entrepreneur you get a
lot of the moral benefits that regular
entrepreneurs don't get but you don't
get a lot of the cash benefits so I'll
talk to you about that the second reason
that I'm a bit emotional today is that
this is the first talk I've given in two
months I had a series of emergency
surgeries in December and first world
healthcare access to first world
healthcare is one of those things that
will really make you realize how lucky
we are and also for me made me reflect a
lot on the work that we do addressing
extreme poverty we work at samasource
and at lux me on the issue of extreme
poverty and though the world in many
ways is getting better despite the
headlines about terrorism and climate
change the world for a lot of people has
gotten dramatically better in the last
few decades we've seen a dramatic
decrease in the number of people living
in poverty globally and yet still we
have a world in which about a billion
people are living on less than a dollar
a day it's hard to put that in real
terms so let me humanize it a bit for
you and I'll tell you how it relates to
my own struggle what this means is that
we still have about 300,000 women dying
in childbirth 300,000 avoidable maternal
deaths the World Health Organization
estimates that 99% of these deaths are
solely due to poverty we live in a world
in which close to a billion people live
without access to clean water and about
two and a half billion people live
without access to basic sanitation the
surgery I had was an emergency I was
actually giving a talk at the slush
conference in Helsinki and felt a pain
in my abdomen was rushed to the ER and
had I not been operated on within
24 hours which had I been in northern
Uganda or had it been a citizen of many
developing countries living at this
income level I surely would have died I
found that out from the doctors that
gave me the surgery then I had this
infection and I was hospitalized for two
weeks and luckily my travel health
insurance covered the entire bill but
for so many people living at this income
level one catastrophic health event will
catapult the entire family into extreme
poverty and debt or lead to death so
this is what life is like for a billion
people around the world imagine that
this is completely unacceptable in 2018
I felt that it was completely
unacceptable ten years ago when I
decided to devote my life to this and
I'll tell you a little bit towards the
end how I got started in this industry
but really briefly I was living in
Southern California as a high school
student I got a scholarship from of all
places a big tobacco company called
Lorillard for community service in high
school and I decided to use it to go and
do a volunteer exchange program I was
not so much motivated by idealism as by
the idea of leaving school and having an
adventure so I graduated a semester
early and I went to Ghana in West Africa
and I volunteered as an English teacher
and I became really close to people who
lived at this income level and I saw so
much avoidable tragedy that as an
undergrad I couldn't ignore it I kept
going back to Africa and I decided I
wanted to do something about this and
make a difference in my life through my
career so that's how I ended up here so
these are the stats right we have a
billion people living in this kind of
poverty and just to give you a more
human picture of this this is someone
who used to live at this income level
kenka Hara with his little daughter
Roslyn I met Ken about four years ago in
Mathari which is a really awful slum in
Kenya where about half a million people
live that's what Mathari looks like and
ken was supposed to be one of the
success stories ken had actually gotten
lucky enough to get a scholarship to a
boarding school in Kenya so he had
graduated with top marks from this
boarding school and you would assume as
a westerner that after this Ken's life
is secured right he's going to go to a
good college he's going to get a job he
and his daughter will
a happy life but Kenya faces 70% youth
unemployment many of the people living
at a dollar a day are actually working
full-time this is hard to imagine we
think maybe if you're not making much
money it's because you're sitting around
and like you know eating coconuts or
something but the reality is that a
billion people work full-time and still
earn less than a dollar a day ken was
one of those people after he finished
high school worked really hard managed
to get this scholarship gets a diploma
no one offers him a job it's really
tough if you come from a poor background
in a poor country to get into the formal
economy and get an office job so ken was
stuck going back to the informal economy
he moved back to the slum and he made a
living picking bits of plastic and metal
from those junk heaps that you see and
selling them to the local recycler which
made him about a dollar a day later he
ended up boosting his income many of the
young men in this slum young men and
women are incredibly entrepreneurial and
run lots of side hustles so one of Ken's
side hustles was actually brewing a kind
of moonshine called chunga and what you
see here in those barrels are these guys
brewing chug on now initially I thought
this was kind of a fun story here's this
guy selling bootleg liquor to make some
good money until I heard what Cheung God
does to people in the Salemi actually
mix it with kerosene and ken told me
that people drink this stuff to forget
themselves this is what people are doing
now to earn a living people working
really hard people who speak the Queen's
English like Ken probably better English
than I do this is a waste of human
talent this is a massive wasting human
of human talent I think that's actually
the biggest problem in the world is that
we're wasting the most important natural
resource on the planet which isn't gold
or diamonds or lithium it's the talent
at the bottom of the pyramid now what is
our approach typically to helping
someone like Ken in this horrible
situation well
it's charity we think life is gonna be
better for Ken if we build him a school
or if we build them a well if we send
food aid if we send shoes and supplies
and this way of thinking actually
started in an unusual way it started the
era of international aid after World War
two it started during the Marshall Plan
the term care package how many of you
have received the care package
people still do that in undergrad okay
for you you have really sweet parents um
back in my day when I was an undergrad
people would get care packages from
their parents and I didn't know that the
term originated after World War two when
Americans would send food aid to poor
Europeans who were rebuilding their
countries and these packages came they
were called care packages is an acronym
for a non-governmental organization that
got started after World War two during
this era when we were rebuilding Europe
now this was initially meant to be a
short term measure right let's send food
to Europe
let's help rebuild these countries and
then we'll stop needing to send food
they're gonna be able to take care of
themselves but what started as a
temporary stopgap became a permanent
industry and after Europe started
rebuilding itself these organizations
which had allocations from Congress
started looking at ways that they could
send food aid to other countries and the
modern era of international aid began we
sent billions of dollars in food aid and
grain and other sources other supplies
to poor countries over the years we've
transferred a trillion dollars of
development aid from rich countries to
sub-saharan Africa alone in the last 60
years and yet real incomes for the
poorest people in sub-saharan Africa
have remained flat something is really
wrong with this picture
and I argue and many social
entrepreneurs argue that there's a much
better solution and that's to move away
from traditional charity what often
makes us feel good but doesn't result in
long term good outcomes for the people
we want to help people like Ken and
think about ways that we can empower
that talent at the bottom of the pyramid
and give work instead of giving a this
seems probably really obvious to you
that if it's possible why wouldn't we
give someone a job but you would be
shocked at how much our thinking I think
has been shaped by the traditional
charity model and how often we do what
feels good what might make us get a
little dopamine surge because we're
giving someone
and out and we see a smile on someone's
face then what actually does good in the
long run and we now have increasing
amounts of data that the best thing to
do for low-income people is not to give
them stuff but to ensure that they have
income there have been a number of
studies that have shown that when we
give poor families income they tend to
do they tend to spend that money on all
the right things on exactly the sorts of
things that the most successful aid
program would design especially if we
give that income to women women are
shown to reinvest 90% of their income in
the health and education and well-being
of their families and communities so
there's really no better aid program
than providing work to low-income women
so we can give income in two ways right
we can give it directly as cash we have
a fancy way of saying this in the world
of international development we call it
direct cash transfers or better we can
give it in the form of work work is
beneficial for so many reasons because
not only do people get this influx of
cash which they tend again to spend on
the right things contrary to popular
belief there's now lots of data and if
you go to our website it's on the source
dog you can find it
but in addition work gives people
stability work gives people a community
and work gives people dignity a feeling
that they're contributing as equal
partners when someone earns an income
they're engaging in a relationship in a
transaction and I think that's a really
powerful thing especially for someone
like Ken who's been denied the chance to
work in the formal economy there's one
other thing that work does which is
really interesting and not always very
intuitive which is that work builds more
stable economies imagine if you govern a
poor country in sub-saharan Africa where
is your budget coming from to govern the
country well in many cases it's coming
from outside the country it's coming
from foreign donors so ultimately if you
govern that country who are you
accountable to well if you follow the
money you're accountable to people
outside the country are not accountable
to your own people who can't afford to
pay taxes and what this does is it
creates a really corrupting influence of
foreign aid money a much healthier
relationship between people and their
government is built when people earn
money when that money is taxed and then
at least a semblance of a
contract exists between people and
government now obviously we know that
that social contract is not perfect we
have lots of issues with it here in the
US but even the expectation that
government is making money from my
income therefore government should be
accountable to me is really powerful and
I can't stress enough how many people
like can never get that feeling of
empowerment because they perceive that
there's no accountability there so
giving work is really important at the
individual level at the family level and
we're now seeing increasingly at the at
the societal level so let me tell you
about a new kind of work that's emerged
in the last 10 years since I started
sama and because we're sitting here in
Silicon Valley this new kind of work is
probably more familiar to all of you
than it was to most people I talked to
you this is a spool of fiber-optic cable
so when people say that the Internet is
rolling out across Africa this is
literally what it looks like this photo
was taken in 2012 in northern Uganda
where we stopped by the side of the road
because women were digging this ditch
and laying this fiber-optic cable in the
last few years over 10,000 miles of
fiber-optic cable have gone in across
East Africa this may not seem like a big
deal but it has been revolutionary for
people who were previously cut off from
high-speed Internet and this revolution
has made an entirely new kind of job
possible a job that's not dependent on
traditional infrastructure like big
ports and big super highways and all of
the other other infrastructure that you
need to build factories and create
traditional jobs this is much lighter
infrastructure if you have high-speed
internet you can ramp people up doing
data services work doing all kinds of
work in the digital economy that didn't
even exist 10 or 20 years ago and you
can do that much more cheaply than
building a big factory that requires all
this infrastructure and customs
officials who are going to make sure
your orders get delivered on time
etc so it enables a totally new type of
work and as an example this is one of
those types of work does anybody have an
idea what this image annotation might be
used for
that's exactly self-driving cars right
so there is a massive need in the auto
industry for precise image tagging to
train computer algorithms to do what
humans used to do right to train
algorithms to recognize objects and
images and obviously not just in in the
auto industry but across so many
industries we're building smart Hardware
in shipping and logistics in virtually
every category of industry there's a
need for lots of image tags to train
computers to do stuff that we used to do
and this is exactly the kind of work
that we can train someone like Ken to do
in very little time this revolution in
digital work in the supply chains of the
future which are virtual led me to start
samasource
can't believe it but it's been 10 years
this year here at Stanford sama means
equal in the Sanskrit and I started the
organization because I had had that
experience in Africa I felt really
frustrated the more time I spent working
for large development agencies I after I
went to Ghana I came back I studied
economic development I tried to
understand how it was that a country
that seemed so rich in human capital
where people were incredibly articulate
and passionate many Ghanaians when they
come to the US are wildly successful
because they finally have opportunities
to advance in the formal economy it
didn't make any sense to me that this
country was living on an average of $2 a
day in household income and so I started
digging further and trying to understand
why what we had done in the past didn't
work and I became obsessed with this
idea of social enterprise social
business which is the term that I used
to define sama source and my other
business Lakshmi was really pioneered as
a concept by a guy named Muhammad Yunus
how many of you even heard of Muhammad
Yunus okay good number of hands he's the
founder of Grameen Bank and the winner
of the 2006 Nobel Peace Prize for his
pioneering work in microfinance he as an
experiment in the late 70s decided to
make a small loan to a group of very
poor women in Bangladesh he realized
that lots of poor women had no access to
capital if they walked into a bank they
couldn't
alone and the reason is that the loan
increments were in the lake you know
thousands of dollars instead of in the
tens of dollars so he said what if I try
giving them a tiny loan let's see what
happens will they actually pay it back
and it turns out that the women paid it
back and they had higher repayment rates
than many traditional recipients of bank
loans so he pioneered this concept of
microfinance which we've probably all
heard of which has made a dramatic
difference in the lives of hundreds of
millions of people and alongside this
model of microfinance Yunus developed a
concept which I think is even more
world-changing and powerful which is the
idea of a company that has a social
mission first and foremost so it's
basically a company that operates as a
non loss and also non dividend
enterprise here in the US we don't
really have a category for such a
company you can operate a nonprofit that
way but the idea is that you make a
profit you put all the profit back into
the business and you have a social or
environmental objective so that's
generally the idea of social enterprise
there's different flavors of it you can
make modest amounts of profit you can
make lots more profit personally I
define social enterprise as an
enterprise in which people and planet
are put at least alongside profit and
probably above it and in the case of
sama source what I wanted to build was a
company that would measure itself based
on how many people we moved out of
poverty each year and at what cost to
donors I actually started samasource as
a nonprofit because back in 2008 when I
launched I launched by the way in
September of 2008 which is the worst
month probably the last hundred years to
have started a non-profit and I started
it as a nonprofit because I asked tons
of BC's along santol road I pitched
everyone I could find about this idea
and they all thought it was like
ridiculous beyond belief like they're
pretty risk tolerant but at that time
the idea of building an internet-based
business and I'd selected Kenya as the
first place I wanted to work in a place
in a country where there was no
fiber-optic access where the only
internet was satellite based and where
most people made less than $2 a day
seemed kind of crazy so I was turned
down by all of the for-profit funders I
could
find and I decided to lunch it as a
nonprofit because the only people who
would give me money were people who
wanted to make donations and wanted to
see those donations used for a
sustainable business model so that's how
we launched and we started I had a
little experiment running in Kenya I had
met a guy who was running an internet
cafe with four seats at the time so four
desks and four computers and like many
internet cafe owners in developing
countries he wasn't making much money
because most people couldn't afford to
spend with $1 per hour that his you know
his costs were running so he was running
this unprofitable internet business and
I found him through an entrepreneur
network in Kenya and I said look I have
an idea what if we instead of using your
computers to you know to rent the space
and let people lease the Internet what
if we hire low-income people from the
slums and do tasks for Silicon Valley
companies probably the only thing I'm
good at is I can go and talk to anyone
and get them to hopefully give us a
contract and you're good at running a
business in Kenya so let's partner and
that was our first delivery Center what
started as four computers in Kenya has
now grown into a global network of close
to 2,000 full-time workers were the
largest data services provider in East
Africa and we've served all of these
customers and last year we actually
became profitable off of our earned
revenue working with clients including
Google and Glassdoor so it's been an
incredible journey and one that I could
never have imagined starting from this
very humble beginnings and I think
what's most exciting about the model and
how we've seen it grow over the years is
that the least of our problems has been
the talent everyone at the beginning
said including people at big foundations
when we decided to go the nonprofit
route said there's no way that you're
gonna get poor people from a slum in
Kenya to do computer work like they need
mosquito nets how are they possibly
going to use computers and I think we
have a lot of paternalistic views about
low-income people that very quickly get
dispelled if you spend time in a place
like a slum in Kenya where people just
to survive have to be 10 times more
entrepreneurial than we do if you may
to the point where you're 18 and a high
school graduate in a place like Mathari
you have the most robust set of
entrepreneurial skills you can imagine
and so we actually find that the least
of our challenges is training and
preparing workers to do digital work the
challenges are more in terms of
infrastructure and logistics and scaling
up in environments that are not always
built for her large-scale enterprise
what I'm even more excited about beyond
our presence in East Africa we now
operate centres in Kenya in southern
Uganda this Center in northern Uganda
which I'll tell you about in a minute in
India and in Haiti this Center is super
exciting because it proves that this can
be done not only in an urban location
like Nairobi but in a really rural area
did any of you see the Invisible
Children video that went viral a couple
years ago about Joseph Kony if you have
you haven't seen it it's like extremely
moving and it'll definitely make you cry
I recommend it but it's a movie about
this warlord who abducted child soldiers
in northern Uganda and there was a long
drawn-out civil war that went on there
for 20 years
in this town in Gulu you will see many
more NGOs than businesses and what this
region of Uganda is mostly known around
the world for is this civil war no one
would ever imagine that you could walk
into a centre like this and see people
tagging images in a place like Gulu we
got a grant several years ago to build
the first data centre in northern Uganda
and we used it in an unusual way we
spent it on shipping containers so we
set up this data center inside shipping
containers that were welded together
with solar panels on the roof it started
out off-grid and we've now employed over
400 people in this region doing all
kinds of image tasks one of the most
surreal things ever happened to me is
walking into the centre and seeing a
project that we had going for Getty
Images where people were tagging
pictures of Kim Kardashian and Rihanna
for their celebrity image archive so
like Kim Kardashian's selfie habit is
addressing poverty in northern Uganda
just like really wild but what's
exciting about this is that now this
model in northern Uganda is operating
profitably so provided
we have the capital to make long-term
loans you could set up a center like
this anywhere where you have fiber and
probably increasingly with all the new
technologies that are available talking
about 5g now and how Africa will totally
leapfrog over the West and not need any
of this hard wired infrastructure this
is going to be possible in so many of
the places where people like Ken exist
but don't have access to traditional
jobs the digital jobs circumvent the
traditional mechanism by which people
find work and they liberate people I
think from the confines of today's
capitalism which allows money to move
freely across borders but people are
stuck within them let's talk about the
transformation that happens when you get
one of these jobs so on average our
workers are making under a local living
wage it's actually a requirement for our
workers when they're coming in that
they'd be poor we're probably one of the
only companies that deliberately screens
for low income people in this way
especially in Kenya so on average our
workers are living in poverty their
household income is around $2 a day and
as I've described that puts you at risk
in many ways it means you live in
insecure informal housing that picture
on the left is when I first met Ken his
beautiful little daughter was playing by
what looks like a river but it's
actually an open sewer right outside of
his home he was living in a one-room
home which he constructed himself that's
the kind of life that you have if you're
living at $2 a day and it's not just
that you don't live in a nice house it's
that you're at risk of contracting a
number of diseases ken was actually
orphaned when he was a young man because
his mother and many of her siblings died
of multidrug-resistant tuberculosis
well that spreads in places like slums
it puts you at risk of violence
especially for women women who live in
these environments have to leave their
homes to go to the bathroom often in the
middle of the night they're at risk of
all kinds of violence so it's a risk
factor for many things that can
dramatically reduce your life expectancy
the second thing we see at this income
level is poor nutrition by the way this
data that I'm sharing with you is not
hypothetical this is actually based on
very detailed survey data that we've
collected over the last ten years and if
you're curious you can look at it at
samasource org slash impact we actually
survey our workers at the baseline when
they join sama source six months in a
year out and then three years after
they've left our program to find out
what happens and whether our model
actually works long term so the other
thing that we noticed with our workers
is that they have really poor nutrition
they are many many of our workers in
Kenya we found are actually eating sugar
cane as a primary source of calories
because it's the cheapest form of
calories so not a balanced diet
obviously that leads to various health
problems and even in terms of your
ability to secure work or be happy your
nutrition plays a big role in that
really limited educational opportunities
even if your government offers free
education you still have to pay for
uniforms books and the opportunity cost
of going to school if you live in a
low-income family often your parents
need that support of you going out and
selling stuff by the side of the road to
make ends meet and lastly an adequate
health care I can't stress enough how
much me being in the hospital in
December made me realize how lucky I am
how lucky we all are to be able to go to
the ER here at Stanford if we need to
and how many billions of people are
denied that opportunity simply because
of an accident of birth in Uganda and
northern Uganda if you go to the
hospital and you don't show up with the
equipment needed to perform the
operation that you need so if you need
stitches you have to show up with
sutures and sanitized needles you won't
get operated on that's how bad the
healthcare infrastructure is in many of
the places where these workers people
that can live it's unacceptable
what happens after sama well on average
is so exciting we're able to increase
people's incomes by nearly 400 percent
and they stay at this income level three
years after they leave us and we found
that this is true because they enter the
formal economy once someone has access
to a digital job this is really
different from a traditional factory job
you have access to a world of
information you start googling stuff you
start looking up things like Khan
Academy you start realizing what your
worth as a worker in the modern world
and it's really a transcendent kind of
experience to go from being an informal
worker with little exposure to the
digital economy to a digital worker of
the future a member of the new economy
what do we see materially in our workers
lives how do they change the first thing
they do is they get better nutrition we
literally see a change in the diet
immediately of the people that we hire
we see them buying fruits vegetables and
protein eating a balanced diet for the
first time obviously that makes a huge
difference in their quality of life we
see them move into safe housing this is
a huge one if our workers have children
if they have elderly parents just the
act of moving your family to a safer
place reduces your risk of disease and
violence dramatically we see them pursue
higher education many of our workers our
funding school fees for young children
in the family they're saving for their
own education and lastly healthcare
access and health insurance which is
life saving for the people who enter our
program so a really dramatic shift and
as I mentioned we've now been able to do
this for many thousands of people we've
moved 45,000 people out of poverty in
the last 10 years I mean stayed out of
poverty I want to tell you a little bit
about what we've done here in the US and
it's some exciting to me because it
started with a really weird story it
started with the guy who wrote me a
nasty email we were running ads on Hulu
in the early days and I was showing our
refugee with a program running in a
refugee camp this guy wrote me an email
and he said I think you're ruining
America and you should not have
nonprofit status because you're taking
our jobs and you're sending them to
refugees
so I'm initial response was to write him
a nasty email back and luckily I slept
on that email I didn't send it best
entrepreneur advice by the way and the
next morning I wrote this email I was
like you know maybe you have a point Joe
let me know if you have ideas about what
we could do to adapt our model in the US
Joe turned out to be a recently laid-off
factory worker in Ohio I actually
printed out a copy it put the copy of
the email in my book if you see it it's
really inspiring and he Joe wrote back
with this really nice note saying thank
you so much for listening I've been
really frustrated maybe there is a way
your model could work here and I'm
sorry that I was so insulting in my
email that conversation inspired a
discussion with my board about adapting
our model here in the US and now we run
something called sama school which is a
program that connects low-income people
to the independent economy this is a
crazy stat but almost all net employment
growth in the u.s. in the last decade
occurred in alternative work
arrangements in other words independent
work not nine-to-five traditional jobs
and yet we are not preparing low-income
people for these types of jobs if you go
through a job training program in East
Palo Alto no one's teaching you about
the gig economy
well now except sama school so our
mission is to equip low-income people to
earn a living wage through this new
world of freelancing and independent
work and our trainees are now earning
over $20 an hour which is a huge
increase over traditional minimum wage
or very low wage hourly jobs after four
months we see them earning a couple
grand and supplemental income which is a
big deal if you live at the poverty line
here in the US the federal poverty line
is a family of four earning twenty two
thousand five hundred dollars a year one
in six Americans lives under the poverty
line so a few extra grand might not seem
like a lot but it is life-changing if
you are living at or below the poverty
line and here's an example of one of our
students grace she actually is a
military veteran and a single mom living
in San Jose she was able to start doing
freelance IT work from home which
lowered her childcare costs and she's
now earning over $40 an hour previously
she was a low-wage worker doing
part-time work we think this has the
potential to impact millions of
Americans long-term last year we trained
about 500 people now we've partnered
with the California community college
system and many city based workforce
development programs to roll this
training out across many cities around
the country all right I'll tell you
about one other business then I think I
need to go to questions a couple of
years ago in northern Uganda I started
thinking is there a way I can apply the
samasource model which is really b2b to
a different industry and I came across
this amazing ingredient called
Nautica it's a rare type of shea butter
and it only grows wild at the source of
the Nile River and I started looking at
this product and thinking god it's
amazing it comes out into this beautiful
butter that if you apply it to your face
absorbs really readily and women in the
region use it to massage onto their
infant babies and I thought wow this is
such an amazing product why has nobody
done anything with it why are we
spending $200 on luxury skin creams at
duty-free that are not only not good for
the world but actually toxic for our
bodies as women don't benefit any women
in the supply chain or any women as
owners of these companies why are we
doing that when we could buy something
that's natural and good for the world
with a sustainable Fairtrade supply
chain that elevates women in the same
position as someone like Ken but in a
place like rural northern Uganda many of
these agricultural inputs actually
almost all of them and certainly all
night Logica is farmed or collected by
rural women so I came up with this idea
I went and pitched my board and they
said okay we give you permission to
start this other company and I set it up
so that samasource actually owns 1/3 of
the founding equity in the business so
we have a really unusual setup where
this nonprofit has a big equity stake in
what became a for-profit social
enterprise called luxe me we launched
last year as the first fair trade and
organic skincare brand at Sephora and
nationwide and I think it's a real
revolution that's coming in beauty the
same revolution that happened in food
consumers are looking for ethics in the
supply chains of what they buy and
they're looking for products that don't
poison them so we're building something
really similar to what we've built with
samasource
but for consumers in luxury beauty and
we've really tried to reflect the ethos
of our brand in the packaging so a lot
of our packaging and materials are
inspired by the region in which we
operate
the other cool thing I think about the
brand is how often do to meet the people
in the supply chain of what you buy we
actually show you videos of the people
who harvest these nuts and you can meet
them on our website every product has a
number on it you type that number into
our website you can actually meet these
women and I think more and more
brands are starting to come along and
realize that this is what consumers want
they don't want a product made by a
nameless faceless person that they have
no connection to all right one last note
which is where do we go from here what's
the next step of the social enterprise
movement well this is a stat that I came
across in researching my book which
really shocked me which is that the
biggest 2000 companies in the world
spent 12 trillion dollars on goods and
services annually 12 trillion by
comparison the GDP of olive sub-saharan
Africa is 1.8 trillion this is money
spent on everything from the rugs in the
conference room to the coffee in the
lunchroom to the raw materials in the
batteries of our cell phones if we could
impact just a little bit of this
spending and have it go to social
enterprises that actually lift people
out of poverty and measure their success
doing that how much better would the
world be we could lift millions of
people out of poverty directly by
ensuring or by encouraging companies to
allocate just a small percentage of
their existing corporate spend to social
enterprise I think the potential
especially in b2b especially with
organizations like samasource which
serve large enterprises is really huge
and most of the ethical consumption
movement has to date focused on
consumers when you look at Fairtrade
brands for example most of the emphasis
is on consumer goods like coffee and
chocolate when we start thinking about
the enterprise the numbers become
astounding right 12 trillion dollars the
entire global aid budget is less than 40
billion annually so this is where the
real money is and this is where the
transformation is going to happen in the
next 10 years it's in the way that
corporations do business we've put
together the beginnings of a guide to
corporate procurement officers to find
ethical suppliers for everything from
fibres and clothing like cotton fibers
to chocolate and coffee that their
employees might want and my hope is that
this give work movement really touches
more and more people who have the power
to influence how corporations work and I
sum this all up in a book I'll do some
signings outside all right and by
telling you what happened with Ken
Jara since I kind of left him as a
cliffhanger can I met four years ago as
I mentioned he was living in my sari he
got a job at sama source through one of
our training partners in the slum the
last time I hung out with Ken was in the
fall of last year in Beirut he'd taken
his first international trip Ken was
running a pilot program that we set up
with the World Food Programme to train
Syrian refugees in digital work very
similar to what Ken has done he's now
trained over 500 people in Mathari
Kabara and the Middle East to do digital
work he moved out of the slum and his
daughters going one going to one of the
best schools in Nairobi and I think Ken
is going to become a pioneering social
entrepreneur a political leader in Kenya
going forward this is the transformation
that can happen when we give work
instead of charity when we empower
people when we see them as talented
producers rather than passive consumers
of Aid so I hope that as you pursue your
entrepreneurial journeys as you go back
to the companies you work for you think
about giving work as a viable and
exciting strategy for low income people
around the world with that I'm going to
open it up to questions thank you so
much
[Music]
and I was gonna tell you more about the
struggle of setting up the companies but
I think we can do that in QA over here
[Music]
yeah how much time do i how do i
allocate my time across two companies
and how much time do I spend traveling
the world pitching people you sound like
one of my board members interesting I
think to be honest it's kind of a
terrible idea to run two companies at
once I did it because I felt like there
was a moment and no one else was doing
it and I even thought about hiring
another CEO and I tried to find people
to run elects me and I do think there's
a sort of magic juice that you have as a
founder especially in the early days of
a company that are very hard to transmit
to someone else that doesn't have that
same passion or vision
I did have co-founders in Lux me which
really helped and I was able to raise
capital to hire a team which I didn't
have at the beginning of sama which made
it a little bit easier but it's a it's a
pretty constant struggle and I think the
only thing that's made it possible for
me is that some is a more mature mature
company now for me I said I'm only gonna
do this if if sama you know the main
company that I first started is
profitable once we reach that point
where we're breakeven we're running
profitably we have large enough
contracts that are ongoing that to me
was a moment that I could think about
setting up something else but I I don't
necessarily advise it and I think it's
it's really hard and I do think that one
of the most challenging aspects is that
as a social entrepreneur a big part of
what you do in fundraising is pitch the
social mission so it's a it's kind of a
non-traditional type of funding when
you're pitching impact funds they want
to meet you they want to hear the story
and so I think it takes more out of you
in terms of fundraising than raising for
a traditional company and it does mean
that there's more travel involved so
basically very little personal life a
lot of time on the road and probably not
the best idea to run two companies at
once but if you find yourself in this
position come talk to
I'll give you some tips yeah
the supply grossly exceeds the number of
spots of Allah the question was how do
we train people in our centers and we've
experimented with various training
models we used to run all the training
the training ourselves in the beginning
I would actually go to Kenya and train
people I'd go and get customer
requirements from our first customers
here in Silicon Valley would give me
like this is how we define the task that
needs to be done and give me documents
and PowerPoint presentations and I would
make that into training materials and I
would deliver that training to people in
the internet cafe where we started over
time that evolved we started doing more
and more web-based training and Skype
based training and over time even that
evolved and we realized wait a minute
our core competency is not to deliver
training it's to understand the task and
the customers needs and then deliver
quality work so if we're able to
transmit that to another organization
that can do the training all the better
now what we have our feeder
organizations in many parts of the world
like in Kenya and the some there's lots
of community-based NGOs many of them now
have computing infrastructure but they
have no idea what the market needs are
so they might be training people in
computers but they have no idea what is
required to do an image tagging task
successfully so we've been able to
leverage that infrastructure and we have
train the trainer program essentially
where we teach people these
community-based organizations to deliver
training and then we hire from that pool
and there's more and more of this that
can be automated in the case of sama
school I'm really excited about rolling
our training out to existing job
organizations there are workforce
development programs all over the
country that get our tax dollars we're
often training people to do jobs that
went away 10 years ago or we're training
people in valuable skills like carpentry
or hospitality but we're not teaching
them how to use those skills with modern
work platforms like the gig economy so
we found that being kind of the
intermediary rather than being the
delivery partner on
the ground is the best rule for us what
happens when
great question the question was how do
we think about automation and what
happens when the algorithms get better
at stuff like image tagging how do we
keep up well at the very beginning of
this work I was doing a text-based data
entry so the first contract I got was
from a Palo Alto based website called
Bookshare org and we have his job to
take PDF images and transcribe them into
text files and some of you might laugh
now because you're like why wouldn't you
just use software to do that well in the
time that we have built sama source
software has totally taken that over but
at that time it was expensive to get the
really high quality transcription
especially for images that were a little
bit foggy and hard to read and so at the
time what we see when we started we were
doing what is now done by completely by
software and what I've noticed is that
if you're embedded in a company and have
a good relationship with them and your
good vendor you kind of grow alongside
the product managers and the technology
leaders at those organizations and you
evolve with the industry that's kind of
our job and any services company is
going to tell you the same thing right
any company that's in our category I'll
say one other thing which is that this
this is like what keeps me up at night
but every time I talk to a product
manager at a major tech company recently
I talked to somebody who's at Facebook
Messenger and I was like should I be
worried about these chat BOTS and he
starts laughing and he's like do you
have any idea like what a shitshow
pardon my language so it is like there's
no way that this is gonna humor gonna
get replaced any time soon in this
category and there's going to be a need
for more and more training data as we
you know as we build more of these
algorithms and more categories and we
need more precision in the area of
autonomous vehicles what I found
interesting is that as you get sort of
closer and closer to very high levels of
accuracy you see how much more work it
takes to move up even incrementally
right and what you don't want is for one
of these self-driving cars to hit
someone right so it's like the worst
fear of anyone working in this category
that there's any imperfect data which
means I think that there's going to be
quite a long runway for for tagging in
various categories
they may not look as simple as the
tagging I just showed you it's probably
gonna get more complex we're probably
gonna see it extend into many more
industries but I really think that this
is going to be a need for quite some
time at least until the singularity
happens which is like 2045 right
according to Ray Kurzweil so we have
some time great question so what should
be done to onboard for-profit investors
into social enterprise well there's been
some recent movement some major
investors in the last few weeks have
said that all investment should be
directed to social good which I just
like still can I'm like pinching myself
to believe that this is actually
happening I think increasingly the
consumer is demanding it and
increasingly you know we forget
sometimes that like companies and
investors are people at the end of the
day they're people who go home to
families they're people who go to church
they're people who have values and the
more we see the consequences of I think
capitalism that focuses only on profit I
think the more people are moved to do
something so I feel like within the next
10 years we're gonna see actually the
majority of investment directed into
social and environmental maybe not
social and environmental good but at
least companies that don't do bad and
then the future beyond that is is
organizations that do good we're already
seeing many for-profit investors start
mission-based funds here in Silicon
Valley there are several there's more
and more capital that as people generate
more wealth and don't know what to do
with it that's being deployed and social
good the Chan Zuckerberg initiative is
now a really good example the Gates
Foundation many of the large foundations
here are making what are called program
related investments which are almost
like equity into nonprofits and one of
the most exciting movements I've seen is
that it used to be that people who
manage the assets for big foundations or
endowments were completely divorced from
the mission oriented people right so you
have like one group of people who's in
charge of making tons of money off the
assets who will invest in whatever makes
the most money and then another group of
people who are deploying that capital to
try to do the moe
good and there was like a big wall
between those two divisions
well that wall is starting to erode and
people are now realizing this is really
stupid if we're investing in the very
things that destroy the world that were
them trying to solve through
philanthropy with the gains on that
capital that doesn't make any sense
so I think that some of the biggest
pools of capital are now starting to be
leveraged for social and environmental
good and I'll give you one last story on
this I was at a conference last year at
the Vatican and the most moving thing
happened Larry Summers who used to be
president of Harvard when I was an
undergrad he did various things that
really pissed us off he like opposed the
student living wage campaign there was a
big student campaign to get contract
workers who were not directly employed
by Harvard paid living wages and he
opposed it and he said on stage at the
Vatican but that was his biggest mistake
as a university president he said I now
realize that the biggest power I had was
with the capital that we had as a
university and in our supply chain and
that if we could leverage the money that
we were spending as a big employer
including of contract workers to do more
good in the community that's probably
the best thing that Harvard could do for
the region that we're in and to hear
Larry Summers an economist say that an
economists who used to oppose all these
super hippie campaigns by the student
say that on stage in front of the Pope
it was really inspiring and hopeful to
me and so I think the people who direct
these big pools of capital like
university endowments are starting to
come around and that's it's really
hopeful to me
the question the question is do we see
the summer school concept expanding into
other countries and do we see an
opportunity to expand our work into
other countries so as you can probably
tell from the three things four things
if you include the book that I told you
about my problem is an entrepreneur is
like constantly being you know pulled in
two different directions and the problem
is a social entrepreneur is that you
constantly feel like if you don't do
that you're hurting people right like
you're depriving people of the chance to
move out of poverty if you don't move
into a new region so it feels very hard
to make those calls and to be focused
what we decided to do as a company was
to expand not through direct service
offering so rather than set up a sama
source facility in ten countries next
year we get approached by partners who
want to leverage our model locally and
we teach them how to essentially do our
model this is what Muhammad Yunus did
really successfully with microfinance is
he at one point realized okay I've
created Grameen Bank I now have a bunch
of borrowers I don't want to make
Grameen banks in fifty countries next
year but what I can do is go and consult
to other organizations or other
entrepreneurs who want to set up their
own microfinance institution and he
created an industry out of what started
as one organization that's what we are
trying to do with impact sourcing this
idea that through the digital supply
chain you can move people out of poverty
so we set up a consulting arm we call it
advisory services and we now consult to
a range of organizations that want to
implement a version of samus source
locally that's how we did that refugee
program that I mentioned Ken was there
training a local organisation to do
digital work I think there's a really
interesting co-working model concept we
actually piloted it in Kenya and made it
profitable within six months we set up a
co-working space I think it had ten
computers and we said can we make this
profitable within six months doing
freelance work so can we train local
people to do work on a platform like up
work and pay the cost of running the
cent
within six months and we made it happen
so theoretically you could then train an
army of entrepreneurs to set up these
like community co-working spaces in
places where the economics work and do
digital freelancing there are some
constraints of course you have to have
literate people you have to have enough
infrastructure but there are hundreds of
millions of people who could
theoretically do this work so I think
the opportunities are really exciting
we're about 50/50 so we do look at
gender and our hiring process and we
want to maintain gender parity
personally I think it's a little bit
concerning there's been a lot of efforts
on elevating girls in low-income
countries which i think is really
important but if we totally exclude the
young men I think we create lots of
issues so we really try to encourage
gender balance and I think it creates a
healthier working environment as well
some of our partners that do the
recruiting will focus on one gender we
have a partner that worked with women
who are victims of domestic violence for
example in India but when they come to
the center we try to maintain balance
what is the number on the VC stuck
together put together this big pot of
cash or big pot of work what would it
take that's a good question and then
there's of course the question of like
relative poverty - right so like we deal
with both poverty in a developed world
context like the United States people
living on less than the u.s. you know
poverty line and then we deal with
people living on less than a global
poverty line of about 250 a day and
there are about you know over two
billion people living on less than 250 a
day adjusted for purchasing power so it
would probably take tripling those
people's incomes
and then you deal with a question of
what impact does that have on the cost
of local goods and services and if you
triple their incomes in dollar terms
right
that doesn't necessarily triple their
purchasing power you know immediately
right so probably some economists
somewhere has done the math I personally
have it but you know it would certainly
add warf the current aid budget and I
don't think that money has to or should
come from philanthropy I think that
money is going to in the next decade
come from corporate supply chains and
private investment more and more and if
each of us here decides if we're gonna
start a company we're not gonna settle
for starting a company that like makes
an incremental change for the lives of
rich people please don't do that
it's pathetic to me how much capital has
been raised and deployed in Silicon
Valley like building I mean not until
this kind of building like a smart oven
for rich people like okay great but like
if you work at that company don't you
want to do something meaningful in your
life don't you want to make life better
for someone like ken to me like we
shouldn't be able to sleep at night
knowing that there are people like this
in the world and that there's so much
money being spent on things that I think
are really not that exciting problems
and I will tell you you may not make as
much money in this kind of work in the
short term I think in the long run this
will prove out to be the most valuable
companies will be those that drive the
most social and environmental impact so
it's just a matter of time and hopefully
we won't be dependent on charity budgets
but I don't have a number I'm sorry
[Applause]
you